We said risk assessment is challenging,
we don't understand all the threats,
we don't know what our vulnerabilities
are of course, so it's two playing two.
Likelihood of a successful attack
of course is going to depend on
what sort of vulnerabilities you might
have and who's trying to target you.
But we said, well if you can
come up with a probability and
what happens as a result of an attack,
then you can compute the risk,
that's how you quantify or
assess the risk.
And you can try to reduce it, but
that's really a question of
managing that, how do we manage?
What options do we have for
managing the risk that our business
is exposed to on the cyber front.
So we talked about assessing it, but
if it's too high, then of course,
we'd like to reduce it.
So how do you reduce cyber risk?
As we said before we get into reduction,
assessing required the likelihood
as well as the impact.
So how do you assess the impact?
It's the expected loss we're talking
about, so it's expected losses,
really loss multiply the probability,
so we do have get to the loss, and
when you talk about loss it
could be reputation loss,
target of core suffered
including degrees and sales.
It's the cost of calling somebody in.
So, for example, if you're Sony and
you call FireEye or Mandiant to
come figure out what happened,
I'm sure they paid for that Mandiant or
FireEye got compensated really well.
Your response, it may be legal costs,
you may have to buy identity theft
protection for your customers and
things like that.
It's real dollars, reputational.
What you do in the aftermath.
All that has to add up
to sort of the cost or
the loss that you would
attribute to a certain attack.
And expected I said was that value
multiplied by the probability.
So that's really risk.
Risk was probability times impact,
so maybe the impact is a loss.
So let's just talk about loss here.
So this one would still be talking
about you're assessing risk.
Now let's talk about
how do we manage risk.
So the only three things you can do once
you come up with some sort of a risk
estimate.
You can say well, I can live with it.
In that case, you're accepting the risk.
You may want to transfer it.
So the risk is transferred
to another party.
So if something bad happens to you,
the consequences or
the cost is going to be
borne by somebody else.
That somebody else is going to
do it only if they are paid
to be in that business.
And that business is
the insurance business.
So you can buy insurance.
And by buying insurance, you're
transferring it to whoever insures you.
The other option is you can reduce it.
How do you reduce it?
Well, you're going to reduce it by
deploying new technology solutions, and
maybe a more expensive,
more effective firewall.
You can reduce by educating your people
or having training and things like that.
More security awareness,
of course, is going to ensure that it's
less likely that they make a mistake, so
that's going to reduce the likelihood of
the probability of some adverse event.
Which we know a factor,
the way we compute our risks.
So, managing once you have
an estimate of the risk,
there are a couple of options on
how you can deal with that risk.
As we said this transfer thing
happens in a lot of other domains.
You buy insurance for your car, for
your health and things like that.